-That is hard work right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is so heavy, man.
-Can I feel it?
-Yes. They told me
to never put it down,
because people
have been known to steal it.
You know, occasionally,
I'll just set it down
to talk to somebody.
And they told me that they stole
Frances McDormand's last year.
So no matter what you do,
keep it on your person.
So, literally, on the plane
the whole time, I'm spooning...
I was spooning with --
-With your Oscar.
-Yes.
-Let me just feel it.
Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah, it's --
-Wow. It feels great.
It's a legit --
It's a great award.
-It's -- Yes, it's a weight
I'm willing to carry.
-Well, thank you for
making it back here.
Welcome home.
-I made it back.
Yes, I barely made it back.
[ Laughs ]
-What have the last
24 hours been like for you?
Did you -- Have you slept?
-Oh, no, absolutely not.
-Yeah.
-I did the, you know, the --
whatever they call
the exit where you, like,
just back out the room
and kind of just disappear,
you know,
'cause I was wise enough to --
'Cause when you're nominated
for an Oscar
and it's that far in advance,
anxiety starts to set in.
And, for me, I was
wise enough to figure out
how to distract myself
in this moment.
And, of course,
anyone who knows me well,
either on the Internet
or you personally,
you know that there's no
deejay gig
I won't ever turn down.
And to do the
Jay-Z/Beyoncé Gold Party
is one of the hardest things
ever to do in life,
like, to please
that many people in that --
-Yeah. So you purposely chose
that you're gonna deejay
Beyoncé's and Jay-Z's party
because that'll be
more pressure in your head.
-Oh, up until that --
Once I accepted that gig,
then it was like,
"Oh, what Oscar?
I don't care."
But, at night, I'm like, "Oh,
I got to pick out
the right song."
-What are they saying --
Yeah, yeah.
-Right. So, I...
-Did you end up playing
Smash Mouth?
-I forgot we had a bet.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I played
"Smells Like Teen Spirit,"
which is -- No, Jimmy and I had
a bet that my first song
was gonna be Smash Mouth,
"All Star,"
which I don't think is what
Jay-Z really wants to hear.
-But what if they were like,
"Oh, here comes Questlove.
What's he going to play?"
-I know no one that fronts on
"All Star."
So it's like,
when you put it on,
you're forced to sing it
against your will.
-You have to, including Jay-Z.
-Exactly. So --
-He would be like...
♪ Somebody once told...♪
-Right.
-And he would get into it.
Anyway...
-So, I'll tell you this much.
And there was one point where
it just became, like,
a cyclone of a mosh pit.
And inside this mosh pit of
just jumping people,
I see Anna Wintour
sort of, like, in the thing.
-So I think --
-No way. You did well.
-Yeah. I think that if I do
the Met Gala,
then I'll start off with
Smash Mouth.
-Alright, alright. Perfect.
-There you go.
-When you're in the crowd
and they announce your name
that you won and everyone
gives you a standing ovation,
when you're next to your mother,
what is going through your head?
And how -- Did you --
I mean, you got emotional,
but I would have been --
I was crying in my living room.
-We were the only
two people in the room.
Like, it was that moment
that I realized that, like,
we went through so much,
like, from, you know,
them sacrificing
to put me in music school,
and, you know, it's like
either our bills or my future.
And I just thought about
all those moments
and -- You know,
and, of course, you know,
that happened in the cyclone of
a whole 'nother situation
with two very good
friends of mine.
And I really
wasn't aware of that.
It's weird to say,
because, you know,
they tell you ahead of time,
"This is your category."
And so, in that moment,
you are either going to be
full of anxiety, or, for me,
like, I've been, like,
meditating for like
the last two years.
So I do trans-med -- Actually,
Seinfeld taught me about that.
Like --
-T.M.
-Yeah, T.M.
And, you know, a minute --
When the commercial break was
happening, I was
just in my "Mmmmm."
So, when I opened my eyes,
I didn't realize --
like, "Why is everyone
so quiet?"
Like, I literally
was not present
for that whole, entire moment.
And as I'm walking to the stage,
I'm kind of putting
2 and 2 together
and I realize that that
was a real moment like
maybe three seconds
before I spoke words.
But, in my mind, they're just
doing a sketch or whatever,
and I'm just like, "Okay, Ahmir.
Remember to thank your mom,
your dad, thank..."
-Really?
-So I was not present at all.
I was just in a blank space.
-And did people sitting
around you have a vibe, too?
-I was in the fun section.
I was -- I was right -- Like,
I was in the documentary --
They put the documentary people
and the animation people,
so the "Encanto" --
Like, that whole --
They were having,
like, Hot Takis and Fritos.
-How did they smuggle that
into the Oscars?
-Dude, it -- We had a picnic.
Like, they were sharing,
like, snacks with me.
-You looked great.
Your mom looked great.
I want to show a picture
of you and your mom, just so --
-You know, I've not --
I purposely have not
watched the highlight reel,
but I hear that --
My mom loves crying at anything.
-Dude, I lost it.
-Like, my first-grade recital,
she cried.
Like, she always cries
at anything.
Like, "Mom, I got a C-minus."
"Oh, my baby!"
Like...
[ Laughter ]
-I just know her from sitting
right in the audience up there
and saying hi to her.
-So, they did a close-up
of my mom?
-Whew! Dude...
-Aw, man! I already know.
-No, dude. I lost it, dude.
I was -- I lost it.
Nancy, everyone.
-I'm not one to go in the --
Like, I don't --
This is an old reference,
but you know, like,
Al Bundy does the whole, like,
Polk High School,
four-touchdowns,
highlight-reel thing.
-Yeah.
-Ask your kids --
Ask your parents.
But, you know, I've not watched
any highlight reel or anything.
So I don't want to get stuck
in that thing where I'm like,
"Just watch it.
Okay, watch me walk
to the stage right now."
-Yeah, yeah.
I can't tell you -- Obviously,
you know we love you
and we're proud of you,
but everybody -- everybody --
who knows you
loves you and is
so proud of you, dude.
It couldn't have happened to
a better dude.
-I'm gonna --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let me just tell you.
I'm gonna tell you, what's --
Just real quick.
And I'm not world-famous for
deflecting any praise
or love or whatever, but I have
to say that, you know,
my true reward in this
whole thing is that, you know,
I'm in this creative atmosphere.
Like, I consider this
30 Rock universe --
Like, I don't say like,
"Oh, I'm going to
'The Tonight Show'
or 'Fallon' or what --"
30 Rock is, like, the
best college I've ever been to,
where I can go to
different floors
and watch people work,
and then they're creative.
And the fact that I, like,
get to create with my friends
over there and with you,
that, to me, is the real --
And I know it sounds like
so a Hollywood answer.
Like, "Oh,
that's my real reward,"
but that, to me,
is what matters.
And the fact that I get to
live out my dreams,
and you provided
this platform for me to --
if I want to write a cookbook
one day or if I want to,
you know, teach class or
start a radio show.
And, like, I didn't even start
to listen to my dreams
until I came here in 2009,
so I really want to thank you
for giving me that platform.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Academy Award-winning director
Questlove.
-Thank you.
-Academy Award-winning director
Questlove, everybody!
Check out his Oscar-winning
documentary, "Summer of Soul,"
on Hulu.